I'm actually the last official person to
drink with you at the Michigan Ohio
State game that we watched at my house
yes we drank the Kentucky out I think
that's why you watch all those old shows
and I think the vibe of your your
stand-up special everything about you is
it's like you were born in the wrong
time or he was born in Pittsburgh
just stayed in like this bubble like a
sci-fi movie is everything else sort of
progressed whatever that means there is
a lot of Pittsburgh that is still in the
bubble but it's also a very Progressive
City and it's a lot of great things
happen in Pittsburgh right now I would
live there in a minute if I wasn't in
this business me too but growing up in
Pittsburgh you know my grandfather used
to own a bar a long time ago and he was
always in bars and I grew up in bars
since I was a little kid so that whole
being around adults in that era that to
me is like that's that's what life is
you said that I've continued that into
my adult life and I don't know how to be
any other way and I respect people I'm
good to people and just chill out relax
yes have a cocktail